there is a lot of infighting on the
right that I think makes us look very
bad one thing about liberals you guys
really do stick together and you
actually get work done even when I don't
agree with it from my perspective as a
liberal I sometimes see y'all sticking
really hard together and y'all are like
no matter what we're going to vote
[Music]
red the far left and the far right are
equally problem itic 3 two
1 I've actually seen both sides I'm a
gay conservative and I have seen the far
right chastise me for my sexuality and
I've seen the far left chastise me for
being conservative I've had my own
address put on the freeway here in Los
Angeles because they feel that my voice
should not be out there so I see the two
sides actively doing harm to those of us
in the middle who have have a really
rational voice and want to express
ourselves in a safe way I appreciate the
like anecdotal experience that you had
um but like I think my issue saying that
like Liberals are more problematic like
I think everyone is what I talk about in
my anecdotal incident is where I have
never had a conservative physically
attack me physically attack me on the
streets for what I am or who I am they
may verbally attack me I've got that
from the left too but the left has
physical attacks on my physical being
out on the streets because I'm
expressing myself so I I mean MTI the
opposite for myself so like you know
like experien is as I said anecdotal
like you know like your experience
completely valid but to say oh Liberals
are like like you know worse like well
it's not that there there's no one worse
which is why I didn't move to strongly
agree my anecdotal experience tells me
that there is a group of people on on
both sides that will do active harm to
someone who steps out of their expected
narrative I feel like for when we talk
about political extremes I think one
there is a lack of desire for
bipartisanship the second thing is this
kind of like playful attachment to facts
uh people on the far left and the far
right whether we're talking about Israel
Palestine or vaccines people seem to
have like very fun uh activities in
terms of just completely making stuff up
regarding these two things um and then
the third thing is the demonization of
political opponents
where people on the far left and the far
right engage in this idea that the
people on the opposite side of the aisle
they're not just different or have
different ideas they actually hate the
country they want to destroy us you know
people get labeled as extremists just
for being even pretty Centrist based on
our small conversation we've already had
here I don't think anyone here is
Extreme but going down the street you
might get labeled you know crazy leftist
or racist or I had to take the shirt off
for real that it's interesting because
when answering this prompt they sort of
hesitated I've I've been on both sides
of the spectrum I used to be what I
would characterize as a radical leftist
now I'm sort of right of Center and I
feel like I get characterized as a farri
extremist quite a bit so I was thinking
what does farri right even mean because
so many people who I deem to be
reasonable are characterized as farri
right and I'm sure people on the left
feel that very same way I've gone and
spoken to different campuses both as a
leftist and as a right of Center
individual and I've never received more
hatred or people trying to cancel my
events than coming to those campuses as
a conservative speaker well do you think
that's because some of that rhetoric
causes a lot of harm on the right side
like a lot of like the things that are
being said maybe in those talks like can
have like lasting impacts on those
students when you're on those campuses
so like you know and on in the other way
like the conservative student or
students might not like care as much
about you know like oh like progress is
being talked about like you know like I
think like there's perfect example d m
just spoke at University of Penn he's he
she they are free to go and have a talk
conservatives didn't come out and try to
cancel that event they didn't threaten
staff they didn't blockade the entrances
they let that event go on Amala goes to
speak and there's rallies they're
pulling fire alarms they're attacking
the attendees there is extremism I'm
sure sure that there is but I don't
think Dylan moany is the right person to
use for your example because of how much
she's a leftist
but she's also had her life threatened
on multiple occasions she's had to move
around a lot because her address
continuously is doxed and she wasn't
even speaking at any sort of event she
was given a free Bud Light can and her
life was threatened I think some of
that's really important to to keep in
mind given the entirety of the show
actually is when we talk about like
canceling or attacking people the
reality is is if you have the power to
do it you will do it and on college
campuses the prevailing thought right
now is generally progressivism so if
they can cancel or if they can bully uh
conservative speakers off campus they'll
do that but then right now because
conservatives don't have power on
college campuses or in some forms of
media they'll say well the left is pro
cancel culture no offense to
conservatives you don't get credit for
saying well we didn't try to cancel
somebody on college campus yeah that's
CU there's like 10 of you you couldn't
do it even if you
want I think there's way more
conservative students than I think
people actually give credit to but maybe
they feel like they need to you know
Harbor those beliefs internally rather
than you know espouse them out loud and
I will say any conserv who wants to shut
down an event or a speech I would wholly
disagree
with there should not be limitations on
Free
Speech 3 two
1 okay I hate this prompt
uh what because we all agree that like
direct calls to violence are not
acceptable I imagine we all agree like
you can't scream fire in a theater um
otherwise I think that like there should
be Nazis on college campuses is like
doing their ideology you should be
allowed to say basically whatever reic
you want as long as it's not like
violating the terms and service of a
platform I do agree that vaccine
misinformation is harmful I do agree
that misinformation relating to
conspiracy theories is harmful but I
don't think the proper way to go about
addressing that is to lock it all down
and to ban it I like the steps that
YouTube is taken where they might put a
note under the video or what Twitter or
the social media platform formerly known
as Twitter uh called X is taking where
they have like the community note system
I was thinking the very same thing as
you of course there are certain things
that you cannot do even with free speech
being present and I'm not sure how you
define hate speech so with some of the
hate speech laws that are coming about I
think those need to be uh re-evaluated
and maybe rolled back because even
people who we disagree with or we don't
like or we view as evil should still be
able to espouse their their beliefs
right for example right now what's going
on with students on campus I don't agree
that Congress and other individuals
should limit what students are talking
about on campus what's going on in Gaza
what's going on in Israel with the
Crackdown on jvp the crack the Crackdown
on students for justice for Palestine
the people who are in power should
understand that students are the most I
would say uh abrasive when it comes to
speaking out against injustices I'm a
free speech absolutist I think that
there should be repercussions to certain
Free Speech but um it's a constitutional
right and yeah that's where I stand with
it I don't want any apps being banned
want people being banned from certain
apps um and I think there's an attack on
our first amendment right right now yeah
so you think no one should be banned
from platform absolutely not so like
someone calls me like the F slur you
like leave them yeah why I call because
that's their right to say that now you
know you can there should be measures
taken to where like I said there are
repercussions of certain speech I don't
think the platform should be able to
remove them but I think you should have
the right to block them like we already
can now because I've lost three
Instagram profiles just for saying oh I
don't think a man a children should have
sex changes under the age of 18 accounts
gone like I've lost thousands of
followers and stuff for just saying
things that I think are just I do have a
question for you actually yeah because I
I can understand why like hearing a word
like that is is harmful and it's not
something that you want to deal with on
a daily basis wouldn't you rather know
who's homophobic though wouldn't you
rather know who's racist yeah these
platforms have the right as private
businesses to say what they want on
those businesses it's not cancel culture
for them to take down slurs and honestly
they're not that great at taking down
slurs anywhere anyway because I get
called a on a daily basis online just
for being a Jewish person fortunate
thing is this internet and social media
has become the Town Square and the Town
Square if you were to take a box and put
it in the Town Square there is no limit
on what you can say and who's to say the
city's going to come down and say you
use the word and we're going to take
your your soap box and you can't ever
come back to my to my city that's
exactly what you're doing when you're
saying the platform has every right to
remove this language you have the option
to go to another platform there's plenty
of we have option to go to another city
then there's plenty of conservative
platforms that now you have no free
speech you have free speech because you
have so many options I think we have to
be really careful when we talk about the
concept of free speech I like the
concept of free speech and I would
defend that across multiple platforms
that's fundamentally different than the
first amendment the first amendment has
nothing to do with like the concept of
free speech the First Amendment
prohibits Congress or state or local
governments from making laws
specifically abridging your right to
freedom of speech like hate speech laws
don't exist in the United States because
there's not hate speech hate could be an
aggravator to an existing crime but we
don't Outlaw certain types of Speech
Twitter does not have a legal obligation
it's a violation of their First
Amendment right to say they have to host
whatever type of speech or tweet that
somebody has on the platform and a hate
crime and a hate incident are two
different things too and I wanted I
wanted to say like if you if somebody
called you you know the f word and then
they said they wanted to kill you then
that's a hate crime and that's not
protected right but a hate hate incident
somebody could call you your f- word and
not say they want to kill you and that's
still protected it be an aggravating
circumstance to an existing crime but
you can call somebody whatever you want
and it's not yeah I often criticize my
own political party three two
one I see that you're on the disagree
side like what brought you there what
brought me here is because I tend to be
a more I guess you could say traditional
conservative in that I don't like to
speak ill of my own party I just don't
for me to go out and air their dirty
laundry out where everyone can see it is
only going to put a blemish on them and
I always want to put my best foot
forward and I always want to put my
party's best foot forward but I will
point out the instances where I disagree
with them privately so that they can
make the necessary changes I've got to
ask I'm so sorry cuz you said you were a
trump supporter right yes this must be
like the thing you hate the most about
him right isn't Trump like the most like
anti-republican attack here the thing I
come from a community where we found our
power in local government I've separated
myself from this idea that I'm going to
speak poorly about Trump because I want
him to put his best foot forward I wish
more liberals did that to be honest I
think a lot of liberals we tend to uh
bash our party on the social media
platforms or we protest a lot right but
I think when it comes to going to these
City Council meetings going to Congress
writing our elected officials we tend to
fall back on that and we rely on social
media and we rely on demonstrations
there is a lot of infighting on the
right that I think makes us look very
bad um one thing about liberals you guys
really do stick together you actually
get work done even if it even when I
don't agree with it where it's the right
with people like us I feel like they see
gay Republicans or conservatives as
useful idiots to be honest that's why I
kind of take issue with saying that I'm
a gay conser conservative or gay
Republican they don't try to cast a wide
net to bring new people over whereas
liberals do from my perspective as a
liberal I sometimes see y'all sticking
really hard together and y'all are like
no matter what we're going to vote red
like y'all seem very unified even though
you're talking about like public like
there's like internal discourse but like
we I feel like liberals feel like
there's a lot of internal discourse
amongst scre we're always yelling at
each other always well that's
interesting cuz Democrats they're
winning a lot more elections right now
you know that's that's another critique
I have the Republican party you know the
midterm elections was they completely
blew it they put out a lot of bad
candidates the left didn't do that they
policies it's like the right stays stuck
on certain things like abortion it's
like we're un they're un budging with
that and it's like all right if we're
pro- lifee let's be pro-life in and
outside the womb you know cuz they only
focus on abortion but what about war cuz
now they want to send everybody over to
Israel so I'm
like violence should never be the answer
to any issue isue 3 two
1 hey there it's Amala hey I'm Destiny
do you want to be in a jubilee video if
so go to Jubilee media.com casting or
click the link below this video and you
can apply now let's get back to it I
mean violence we assuming we have a
functioning democracy I think violence
is bad for two huge reasons one is
because we don't want to condition
people to feel like violence is the
answer to political disagreements and
then two we want people to utilize we
want everybody to be able to utilize
some form of protest against the
government and when we endorse violence
we're now saying it's okay for even
people we disagree with to use violence
and that could be really scary for a lot
of different reasons but I would say in
general a 99% where we're at today in
the United States VI we are not at the
level of where violence is necessary to
enact any kind of political change I I
wouldn't say entire that's entirely true
I mean there's a certain level of
violence happening to marginalize
communities that doesn't mean I
necessarily like agree with violence
when it comes to um the Palestinian re
Rebellion that's been happening in
Israel um I I don't agree with Hamas
killing people like that's terrorism but
at the same time the violent uprisings
that have happened uh most of which have
actually been peaceful but still there
is some sort of violence happening
because they've been oppressed for so
long like back in the Holocaust people
think that oh Jews went peacefully into
the into the concentration camps no we
were violent we we had uprisings we
fought back at a certain point there is
violence in uh in fighting back to
oppression I put agree because I'm not
strongly I don't strongly agree with it
because I'm all about nonviolence in my
life uh what I practice my spirituality
I'm all about nonviolence but at the
same time as I organize and I'm on the
ground and I'm at protest and I'm at
demonstrations by any means necessary
means right quoting Malcolm X that you
have to have some form of disagreement
with the state that's not listening to
your needs as people as free people and
sometimes that takes you know rebellious
actions like burning down Banks or
burning down institutions that are not
listening to you but as black people in
America if we're only demanding liberty
and justice we're not asking for Revenge
we're just asking for equality and
sometimes I think the state looks at us
being a resistant as violence sure yeah
the reason I came over here I was
thinking more internationally you know
if a country is met with violence
there's really only one way to respond
to that I don't think Israel could go to
Hamas and say hey guys can you just not
do that again when Hamas is already
saying that they plan more attacks that
they had on October 7th so I think
Israel has the right to defend
themselves with violence sure I think
there's okay so there's a couple key
things to keep in mind here so one is
when we talk about like violence and
respons political ideas we have to be
really careful that we don't redefine
violence to mean literally anything that
we don't like because I've noticed that
like people are doing these things where
like there is a white supremacist
violence against black communities
because of the way money is distributed
with our taxes and people will take that
very academic form of violence which is
and it's okay I think to have this
analysis but they'll take that academic
form of violence and they'll say now we
can kill police officers and burn down
buildings or now we can engage in arent
or destroy
neighborhood my side is misrepresented
by the
media three two
one honestly the media is controlled by
the left I really never see any positive
light shine on conservatives nor the
right in the media ever unless it's
right-leaning media and to your point
what I think is really interesting to
even just look at the conservatives who
are here today this a pretty diverse uh
bunch of people and when I was on the
left my characterization of
conservatives was like white
heterosexual old man and to having moved
over that space and see oh there's way
more people who just happen to have
conservative beliefs or maybe they don't
agree with some of the woke stuff that's
happening right now I think we are often
mischaracterized I do agree that right
now ironically it seems like the left
and the farther left have more kind of
corporate media control in terms of how
images are displayed so you're going to
feel like as if you're conservative that
you're not accurately represented and
the left maybe gets some more fair
representation but on platforms where
conservatives run things holy Christ are
people on the left completely and
totally misrepresented like how many
times have I heard these stupid quotes
from the WF where it's like oh you want
us to rent uh rent everything and own
nothing and you want us to eat bugs and
you're on your 57th booster shot today
if anybody's ever listened to rush limbo
Michael Savage Billy Cunningham like any
these people these guys are not giving
Fair accurate representation to the left
their voices just tend to be more
marginalized or smaller now in media
because of how much corporate control
kind of like bows to the woke agenda I
would say I'd like to push back on that
just a little bit I agree with a lot
what you're saying but uh when it comes
to right-wing media maybe platforms like
the daily wire prageru they're very open
about the fact that they're
conservative a lot of the mainstream
left news they'll present their opinion
as fact um but you know yeah like
someone like Ben Shapiro he'll clearly
he'll tell everyone you know listen to
my show listen to POS sa America figure
out what you think is right listen to
the and you could figure out the facts
based on what we're both saying uh you
don't see that as much from the left I I
want to push back on that because Ben
Shapiro has has stated a lot of opinions
as facts I don't think I I think that
there are better examples to use within
the conservative party that are that are
more open about being opinionated but
Ben Shapiro is not or Michael no saying
transgenderism should just be eradicated
from society so now y'all are really
giving them a bullet to use against us
it's the culture War
bull just like that's what I'm so sick
of between both sides because I do think
that both sides are are misrepresented
within media they went way too hard with
the bug Light thing I'm like let's it go
especially on this topic now I think in
2020 we all can agree every news station
besides uh most conservative news
stations and podcasts were posting black
squares and saying that they were black
people but now you know what's going on
with Israel and Hamas you see some media
companies taking the silent side or
firing correspondents on CNN like Mark
Lamont Hill or firing other people on MS
NBC if they have a neutral stance so I
agree with you I think it's a cultural
war on both ends right you have some
liberal um apparatuses who don't agree
with some things that some liberals say
same with the right and how they did
Tucker Carlson both uh liberal and
conservative media even though even if
they say they're blatantly stating facts
they're failing to
contextualize those facts because a
story presented with blank facts looks
very different when you actually hear
like the the buildup and like really see
what's going on underneath mainstream
media tends to misrepresent
conservatives we we all can agree on
that but what they do very well is they
misrepresent liberals in a positive
light we can all remember the news
anchor going it's a mostly peaceful
rally and there's a building burning
behind him they've misrepresented the
other side saying look this side is all
sunshine and rainbows everything's fine
pay no attention to those people being
hurt in the back and instead of actually
elevating people who were advocating for
peace and saying please don't destroy
these buildings they focused on the the
the the destruction and everything else
but not the actual destruction so I see
both sides being completely rep
misrepresentative but misrepresented in
different ways the right being ignored
and cast out as crazy and the left going
we're the shiny example of tolerance
look at us when underneath the surface
we see the truth
the American dream is still alive 3 two
[Music]
1 I feel like when upward class Mobility
is so hard as it is right now um the the
American dream is is it's either dead or
it's on life support because it's just
damn near impossible for people to climb
out of poverty everyone thinks that
they're going to be the next Jeff Bezos
you're closer to being on Skid Row than
you're ever going to be to Jeff Bezos I
think the American dream has become the
American memory like I was thinking
about this um just outside of politics
like you know how a lot of people have
Nostalgia for like the past and stuff it
made me look at America and it's like
we're not going to get back the America
that we were post 911 when everybody was
a little more unified outside of the
Patric and everything we're not going to
get the America where where all Races
could get along without people saying oh
your cultur appropriating your uh
microaggressions you know all that you
know all that little stuff that keeps us
divided I I don't think we'll get back
to the America that we grew up in I
honestly don't like I I want to be
optimistic but it's hard I guess I just
don't know that that's the necessar the
point of the American dream I think it
shifts and it changes and it it takes on
the context of the time that it's in
where we had that sort of old school
nuclear family house with the white
picket
that's changing with technology and
corporations buying up properties and
things like that but I don't think the
American dream is dead I think it's
taking on a new form I think still there
is no no better place to be uh no better
place for progress and as you watch
people in in other countries what are
they influenced by they're influenced by
America where do they want to be they
want to be in America so it speaks to me
that the dream is very much still alive
opportunity is very much still alive it
just looks different the dream or the
idea the dream a dream I agree strongly
with what you're saying here you know
that dream of being able to buy a house
having the nuclear family being happy uh
that's still my view of the American
dream it is harder to attain that's for
sure it might be dead here in
California York it's not I can sure you
I want to believe that the American
dream can be like real The more I've
experienced life the more I feel it is a
little more on the dead side like it's
like this idea that we're taught when
we're growing up is that
you work the hardest you're going to get
the most right like but that's just not
true like and that's not the world we
live in and I know it's a little
pessimistic as I said like I want to be
like the poverty cycle breaker in my
family but it's like it feels next to
Impossible sometimes it may feel Out Of
Reach but um I started my adult life
with $35 in my pocket and I was runaway
because my parents locked me up I saw
them achieve the American dream of
having a home and having beautiful
children I wanted that and I worked hard
and now in my work in real estate I see
people achieving the The American Dream
all day long sometimes California is a
little outside of our price range we got
to go to another state but that
potential that idea that I am free to
choose to get a home choose to get land
choose to start a business that is still
here and I wholeheartedly believe that
the American dream still rests in our
hands we just have to be strong enough
to take it I think for individuals who
immigrate to America the American dream
may still be alive and and embedded
within their Spirit but I think for byac
folk that are within America the
American dream is sort of a memory and
it's it's becoming uh less uh vibrant
due to the housing crisis due to like uh
you said earlier gentrification due to
the lack of Education when the American
dream was first you know promoted within
the 1960s Reagan Nixon the they they
funnel so much money within the American
economy for people to go to college and
not worry about it for people to afford
a home and not worry about it for people
to get a car and not worry about it a to
a minimum wage job and support a family
thank you but now since there's so many
instances of people on the top you know
uh making sure they hold that wealth we
see so many bipac folk in America
America suffering suffering and not
being able to get to that middle class
right American middle class is no more
is is no longer here so you're speaking
just from the bipo perspective not
American I'm speaking just from the bipo
perspective isn't isn't like the
American dream supposed to apply to
everyone and I think that's the issue
it's like when I heard you I'm like I
think that's amazing that like some
people do have the access to move and
stuff like that but like what do you say
for those people at the bottom who are
working so hard and they can't like they
just a lot of the views you have of the
American dream get so politically
tainted that one of the things that
sucks is for the cool things that are
happening in America you can't even take
credit for it anymore um I hate that I
chose like the most politically divisive
topics but like for instance like I
personally think the covid vaccine that
was a huge success of United States
Innovation and capitalism I think our
guns are really cool I think that's like
super awesome you could shoot awesome
firearms in the United States and we
proud gun armor from Nebraska it seems
like for all the things that exist that
are good we can't take credit for them
anymore because all of them become so
heavily politically divided that we
start to have this huge Doomer outlook
on everything I think it's really hard
for some people to have that optimistic
Outlook when there is so much in the way
like I as a disabled person we're still
forgotten about with marriage equality
we're still forgotten about when it
comes to health mandates for for a lot
of people from who live this every day
for us the American dream is dead and
it's been dead for a while I just think
like as a fin the fact that we're all
here and like clothed and fed and have
water we're here discussing ideas and
like how to make this country a better
place to me that completely signifies
the American dream we are currently
living it that's like as you said like a
really optimistic view like oh look how
far we've come but what if that's not
enough for those people right now like
that sucks for the people living right
now who don't have what they need that's
the beauty of America we are free to
succeed or we are free to fail it's free
to do whatever you want I'd rather be
here I'll just say that I'd rather be in
America
me tooo me too are we all going to hug
yes
hi a pleasant hug big
[Music]
hugs